merci
madame la présidente madame la
secrétaire d'État mesdames et messieurs
les députés j'ai l'honneur de soumettre
la proposition de loi visant à lutter
contre les plastiques dangereux pour
l'environnement et la santé à votre
examen que je fais attentif et j'espère
bienveillant
ces dernières années la France a
renforcé son arsenal législatif pour
mieux lutter contre la pollution
plastique il reste cependant tant à
faire pour imaginer un jour juguler
cette pollution
omniprésente dans la terre la mer est
jusque dans le corps humain
la loi relative à la lutte contre le
gaspillage et l'économie circulaire
dites-lois avec portée en son temps par
brune Poirson constitue la pierre
angulaire de notre dispositif pour
lutter contre la pollution plastique
elle acte en particulier une
planification quinquennale pour
atteindre en 2040 l'objectif 0 plastique
à usage unique
elle établit également de nombreux
interdictions et obligations d'usage et
d'emballage à travers cette loi nous
avons été aussi parmi les premiers pays
en Europe peut-être le premier à prévoir
l'interdiction des microplastiques
ajoutées dans des produits tels que des
cosmétiques les peintures et les engrais
aujourd'hui la Commission européenne
porte ce projet au niveau européen dans
le cadre de la révision du règlement
REACH nous avons aussi nous avons aussi
beaucoup fait en faveur de l'information
du consommateur avec la généralisation
du marquage sur les caractéristiques
environnementales des produits nous
avons dans le même temps limité
certaines allégations environnementales
trompeuses ou abusives la loi azec a été
complétée sur certains points par la loi
portant lutte contre le dérèglement
climatique et renforçant la résilience
face à ses effets dite loi climat et
résilience elle interdit notamment les
emballages en polystyrène au 1er janvier
2025 s'ils ne sont pas recyclables et
recyclées avec mes collègues de
plusieurs groupes politiques de la
majorité de l'opposition nous n'avions
porté un même amendement pour mettre fin
à ses emballages jamais recyclés et dont
la toxicité pour la santé et
l'environnement fait l'objet de travaux
scientifiques nombreux
parmi ces députés ils étaient nos
anciens collègues marinafaz Lauriane
Rossi François Michel Lambert dont je
n'oublie pas l'engagement contre la
pollution plastique et je veux les
saluer ici en votre nom le choix du
Sénat d'ajouter à cette interdiction une
condition de recyclabilité a ensuite été
validé par la commission mixte paritaire
à travers la peau position de loi que
nous examinons aujourd'hui je mettais
autorisé à soumettre à nouveau cette
question à la représentation nationale
j'avais en effet estimé que les
engagements solennels prient devant le
Sénat par les industriels regroupés au
sein du consortium ps25 n'était pas tenu
avant la fin 2021 il devait nous
apporter la preuve qu'une filière de
recyclage de PS serait opérationnelle au
1er janvier 2025 ou à défaut définir une
trajectoire de sortie progressive du PS
un rapport a bien été produit en
décembre dernier mais il n'a pas fait
l'objet d'une analyse indépendante ni
public ni privée qui nous aurait permis
de valider les allégations du consortium
ps25 en commission
nous avons fait le choix de ne pas
modifier la loi climat et donc réécrire
l'article premier de la proposition de
loi je ne retirerai rien des arguments
que j'ai pu exploser aux uns et aux
autres sur l'impact du polystyrène sur
la santé et sur l'environnement
j'accepte cependant de considérer qu'il
est compliqué de modifier le cadre
législatif un an à peine après la
promulgation de la loi climat
je ne reste pas moins convaincu qu'au
1er janvier 2025 le PS ne sera ni
recyclable ni recyclé ils ont deux ans
pour finaliser leur concept en
laboratoire et d'industrialiser pour
obtenir les certificats sanitaires et
environnementaux pour lancer la
construction de différentes usines de
recyclage en comptant le temps
incompressible des démarches
administratives pour les rendre
opérationnels et enfin pour recycler
effectivement plus de 50% des déchets en
polystyrène collectées en 2025 la loi
sera appliquée les industriels qui
n'auront pas changé de matériaux verront
leur emballage en PS être interdit de
mise sur le marché je le dis avec
humilité solennité et fermeté du haut de
cette tribune devant cette assemblée la
loi sera appliquée elle le sera quelle
que soit les investissements lancés et
quel que soit les progrès réalisés à
ceux qui refusent la transition
immédiate vers des matériaux et des
pratiques plus durables je leur dis les
fausses promesses de vous font pas
gagner du temps il vous en font perdre
je ne m'attarderai pas faute de temps
sur les questions importantes soulevées
par le recyclage chimique nous ne savons
pas grand chose encore de l'impact
environnemental de ces projets notamment
en termes de rejet de polluants et
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre les
émissions de CO2 du recyclage chimique
par pyrolyse serait jusqu'à 9 fois
supérieur à celle du recyclage mécanique
nous devons donc pas miser uniquement
sur le recyclage à fortiori chimique si
nous voulons respecter les accords de
Paris la lutte contre la pollution
plastique étant cela un enjeu
énergétique majeur pour nos sociétés
appelés à embrasser plus intensément
intensément pardon la notion de sobriété
pour répondre aux crises géopolitiques
et climatiques
il est donc plus que jamais important
d'acter en France et en Europe la fin du
recyclage comme première solution à la
pollution plastique le rapport de la
Cour des Comptes publié la semaine
dernière pointe d'ailleurs notre
incapacité à tenir nos objectifs de
collecte de tri et de recyclage depuis
plus de 10 ans maintenant
nous devons donc
recentrer de recyclage sur les quelques
plastiques pour lesquelles les filières
sont d'ores et déjà très efficaces et
pour le reste mettre l'accent sans
attendre sur la réduction à la source
c'est selon moi l'objet l'objectif
numéro 1 de l'article premier réécrit en
commission
l'exportation des déchets plastiques à
l'étranger est une autre conséquence
dans notre incapacité à gérer les
déchets que nous produisons une pratique
comme le montre un rapport de Human
Right Watch sorti le mois dernier qui
nuit gravement à la santé et à
l'environnement des pays et des
populations exposées l'Union européenne
doit se pencher très bientôt sur cette
question et je souhaite madame la
secrétaire d'État que dans ce cadre la
France défendent une interdiction de
l'exportation des déchets plastiques
hors de l'Union Européenne il faut
mettre un terme à cette aberration
éthique environnementale sanitaire
économique et social
je reviens à la proposition de loi pour
vous dire que voyant les amendements de
suppression je regrette qu'elles ne
fasse pas consensus sur les bancs de
cette assemblée car elle répond à une
demande forte de nos concitoyens selon
le dernier sondage ibsos près de 70%
d'entre eux sont prêtes à changer en
profondeur leur habitude pour lutter
contre le changement climatique un autre
sondage montre que 75% des Français
souhaitent la fin des plastiques à usage
unique
à combien c'est pourcentage monte chez
nos enfants je n'ai pas le chiffre mais
je vois leur extrême préoccupation
devant l'immensité de cette pollution et
j'y vois chez beaucoup le moteur d'un
engagement associatif et civique
puissant je salue à cet égard les
étudiants que j'ai rencontrés dans une
conférence sur l'océan à Sciences Po et
qui ont tenu à être présent aujourd'hui
pour assister à nos débats
[Applaudissements]
l'article de la proposition de loi
réécrit en Commission vise à interdire
des plastiques non recyclés en 2025 il
renforce en cela l'objectif fixé par la
loi Ajac de 100% de plastique recyclé à
cette même date cette mesure n'existera
un suivi régulier et exigeant pour en
assurer d'application au 1er janvier
2025 je souhaite que notre assemblée y
prenne toute sa part
l'article 2 vise à interdire
l'utilisation des composés perfluorés
dans la liste des produits qui comprend
des ustensiles de cuisine des emballages
alimentaires ou encore les jouets cette
rédaction de l'article permet de
coordonner l'agenda national et européen
en votant cette disposition nous
appelons le gouvernement à soutenir
l'initiative de plusieurs pays européens
portés dans le cadre du règlement
européen REACH
en faveur d'une interdiction globale des
composés perfluorés agir au niveau
européen en soutien à la démarche de ces
pays apparaît comme le moyen le plus sûr
le plus rapide et efficace d'aboutir à
l'objectif fixé par la proposition de
loi
l'article 3 a pour ambition de mieux
informer le consommateur il s'inspire de
la directive européenne qui impose de
marquage en particulier des gobelets des
produits du tabac ou des lingettes
lorsque ceux-ci contiennent du plastique
il s'agit de prévenir le consommateur de
la présence de plastique dans des
produits pour lesquels celle-ci n'est
pas évidente l'article a été réécrit en
commission pour viser explicitement ses
produits et non par exemple les
bouteilles d'eau parce qu'il est évident
que tout le monde sait qu'elles sont en
plastique l'article 4 reprend une
préconisation du Congrès mondial pour la
nature l'interdiction possible des
plastiques à usage uniques dans les
espaces protégés le texte s'inspire de
la rédaction de l'article visant à
lutter contre l'hyper fréquentation de
ces sites que nous avions voté dans la
loi climat il s'agit bien de confier un
pouvoir nouveau gestionnaire des espaces
protégés pour que au cas par cas selon
leur enjeu propre une réglementation
soit prise ou non sur tout ou partie de
leur territoire tout est possible mais
rien n'est imposé enfin un nouvel
article a été ajouté en commission à
l'initiative du groupe socialiste et
apparenté pour demander un rapport au
gouvernement dressant la liste des
mesures prévues jusqu'en 2027 pour
accompagner les acteurs publics et
privés dans les réformes de réduction de
l'usage du plastique une planification
concertée et contraignante est
indispensable nous n'atteindrons pas
l'objectif de zéro plastique à usage
unique en 2040 par les seuls engagements
volontaires des acteurs économiques une
planification pour sortir des plastiques
des moins essentiels des moins
recyclables des plus volatiles ou les
plus toxiques une planification aussi
pour maîtriser des conséquences
économiques et sociales de ces
transitions rapides profondes et
nécessaires
je veux aussi remercier l'ensemble des
membres de la commission du
développement durable
pour la qualité de nos échanges sur ce
sujet de la semaine dernière et
particulièrement les responsables des
groupes avec qui je crois nous avons
bien communiqué tout au long du
processus législatif je formule
maintenant le souhait que notre
collaboration perdure pour continuer
ensemble remercier particulièrement
groupe vous invite à la projection du
film cher plastique que fera mon
collègue Philippe bolo mercredi 19h et
merci madame la Présidente
[Applaudissements]